[Musique]
vous pouvez dire que ce n'est pas un
canular
moi je peux dire que c'est pas un
canular alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ce jeudi là à 17 heures précisément il
s'est passé rien de bien à l'origine
rien de bien extraordinaire c'est à dire
qu'on était ici on faisait une séquence
sur le bord du lac pour l'émission les
étoiles ensevelies et puis j'ai fait un
plan de d'illustration un plan b est un
peu cartes postales du lac les fonds il
faisait sombre il était 5 heures du soir
bon j'ai fait mon plan il y avait rien
de spécial n'y a pas de comédie à
l'intérieur du plan les ans était un peu
dispersés autour l'attendait c'est fini
et puis au milieu du plan j'ai vu
quelque chose dans l'oeil temps alors
j'ai vu quelque chose de très imprécis
et ça je les les communiquer à paris
c'est que le phénomène à l'oeil et dans
le temps était beaucoup moins visible
que sur la pellicule
quand on a reçu la pellicule cinq ou six
jours après j'étais très surpris de voir
que est ce que ça faisait du bruit c'est
non pas du tout il ya un certain nombre
de ces petits qu'aujourd'hui vous donner
leurs arguments pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
suivi l'objet alors ça c'est cette
question qui peut paraître évidente
j'ai pas suivi l'objet d'abord parce que
ça s'est passé très vite
j'étais en cadre fixe la caméra était
bloqué ça c'est peut-être un manque de
réflexe on m'a demandé pourquoi
on voyait pas le reflet du phénomène
dans le lac
il ya trois possibilités le reflet est
masqué par la colline qui est à côté du
lac ou alors la portion aussi de ciel
réfléter n'est pas du tout celle qu'on
voit dans le lac
c'est tout simple c'est la géométrie ou
alors la lumière émise par le phénomène
est polarisée et après réflexion sur le
sur le lac hylia extinction si la
polarisation est à 90 degrés c'est un
problème de physique sympa enfin est ce
que c'est possible de faire un trucage
de fabriquer de faire ça de faire un
trucage identique est ce qu est ce qu on
a filmé je pense oui je pense
une somme sur impression pourrait faire
la faire mais ça se verrait ça se
verrait peut-être
[Musique]